you you began with for weddings in a
funeral to cultivate and have offered to
you this persona that we now think of as
a Hugh Grant sort of persona on screen
but before that I was so surprised to
see that that aspect of you come forth
because in movies like impromptu you
were you were the pursued you were you
were more I guess you would say not I
wouldn't go so far as say passive but
you're definitely not Judy Davis is a
whirlwind in that yeah yeah she is she's
the man and I'm very much the innocent
little flower that she's trying to
deflower was that a case of just you
know I I try to ask actors this every
time I talk to them how does it happen
that you are known for a particular
thing and then there would be a phase of
your career where you're known for
another particular thing and then there
will be yet another and and all I always
wonder how much control do you have over
it
how much foresight is there is there a
design or is it just cosmic forces
randomly well I think it's a bit of both
I mean with me
the lovely thing about for weddings
coming along was that it was comedic and
I had the only thing I felt I was
remotely useful in terms of acting was
if there was some jokes around that's
quite good knowing where they are and
trying to bring them out and I
concurrent with that whole career I'd
had up till then doing films and
television
I'd had a comedy show with two friends
which was on my real source of pride and
passion and and so when I went off to do
these films which were rather serious
you know I put on my serious face as
best I could but really I thought I'd be
more comfortable with a few jokes around
and and so that was the good thing about
for weddings when I go that's just that
was I felt like I'm more doing something
that's I can do which other people can't
do whereas if it's deep dark Strindberg
you know ray Fiennes will do that better
so to a certain extent it's not
typecasting it's just doing what you're
best at when we were shooting for
weddings in a funeral or for that matter
when you're working on any film is
point where you think this could
actually work where you have a good
feeling about it and you don't think
you're just being unreasonably
optimistic well I certainly thought that
when I read that script it was a
bizarrely brilliant script I remember
calling my agent and saying I think
there's been a mistake so you sent me a
good script and and which happened one
more time in my career and they sent me
Jerry Maguire and they said yes sorry
there was a mistake that was meant to go
to Tom Brooks but with Four Weddings
yeah well I thought the script was good
and stood a good chance but we were all
pessimists and when we cut the film
together as a rough cut looked at it me
Mike Newell the producers we all thought
Richard Curtis all thought it was a
abomination and we wanted to emigrate
and why don't you think that we just
didn't didn't like it was funny or
clever or interesting and and then they
took it to Santa Monica and had a
screening and everyone went mad for it
and said it just we were wrong and
audiences were right and that was that
was the beginning of what I think of his
face phase 2 yeah yeah yeah that's right
and then you were you're doing things
like nine months for a Hollywood studio
well I did oh yeah I suddenly had the
you know the world at my feet bizarrely
I'd have absolutely no one and I took
forever to choose something to do and I
remember driving my agents absolutely
insane because I didn't really want to
do anything and then this project of
Christopher Columbus's came along and
and I did it and I very nearly ruined it
I bet I did pretty much ruin it I mean
he you know he's a genius really mrs.
Doubtfire and home alone on those things
he's a genius of what he does and
there's brilliant people in that film
Julianne Moore and
Tom Arnold and all those people think
Jeff Goldblum and I just yeah I don't
know why I think I panicked you know
having been paid 20,000 pounds or
whatever it was to do four weddings and
a funeral if you suddenly paid millions
you think well I better ramp up my
performance by 200 times but all that
means is you over act critically which
is what I did so I'm always very
apologetic to those people when you when
you look back on that period do you
think are there are there any parts of
it that you would save in terms of which
bond yes good films well I did there was
some that I signed up for before Four
Weddings came out so an awfully big
adventure is a good film yes so directed
by Mike Newell and the English media
went up a hill is a charming film and
well I liked I liked the thriller no no
one else went to see it but I think
extreme measures I'm quite proud of no
there's plenty in there and of course
Notting Hill is you know people like
that Notting Hill is fascinating
especially if you watch it right after
Four Weddings and a funeral because I've
developed this sort of I guess I would
say a grand unifying theory of Hugh
Grant and one and one part of that is
one part of that is that starting at
some time in the mid 90s your films
start to seem like autobiographical in
the sense that they're about there is
much about Fame and responsibility as
they are the story that they're telling
yeah sorry sorry to lay that on you
without warning but Notting Hill
particularly because the Julia Roberts
character in that movie is the person
who has his besieged by the paparazzi
can't have a moment's peace every move
she makes is scrutinized and you're
playing the average guy you're playing
the ordinary guy which is why she's
attracted to you but I wonder if you
weren't feeling some of the same things
that she was feeling that her character
was feeling at that point in your career
well I suppose I had had some experience
of that yeah but I don't want to put a
pin in your theory but I don't know oh
please do
now whatever wasn't the reason I did
that for I did I I did that from just
because well for the same reason as any
other firm I've done is literally
because it's the best script on the
table at that moment and this one
happened to be Notting Hill it happened
to be winner with a brilliant premise I
mean you know you can sometimes tell
with the one-line pitch line and when
it's you know nobody bookseller falls in
love with most famous woman in the world
it's great I want to see that from
instantly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]